the courtesans does not matter and
really pave the way for our new is to
come who's coming you'll see
join me
[Music]
season finale of Gotham is coming up if
you guys didn't know they're bringing
ratio ghoul on to Gotham I know it's
crazy after we saw him on arrow for so
many seasons but I think at least for
the time being they're pretty much done
with that character and I don't think
that people get confused by that kind of
stuff anyway but multiverse and all
there is a new round of the flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video so if you don't know what's going
on here there is a larger court eval
storyline that's going on is well as
League of Assassins that they're slowly
teasing in with Rachele cool he's just
shown up this whole part of the season
has been all court of owls if you
haven't read that storyline from the
comics and you want to read up during
the summer that's new 52 it was pretty
much like the first big Batman art
during the new 52 back in 2011 but
obviously this being the TV show him
being a younger version of the character
all these characters being a little bit
different they've changed the comics in
a pretty big way so this character that
Bruce has been training with in a very
nanda parbat looking place is called
this shaman now for a little while I
thought that he might be working for
Rachele goal in the way that they had
the big twist during Batman Begins where
you see this person that you think is
raeshell goal but secretly he's just a
henchman
raesha Algol turns out to be Liam
Neeson's character but in the context of
Gotham this character is the leader of
the court about he's trying to Train
Bruce to cleanse the city the same way
that they were trying to do during
Batman Begins with a drug gordon tries
to infiltrate the court of Alice he
finds out about this gas plot that
they're planning to release tries to
defuse it so now the court of owls is
scrambling but they've also brought fish
Mooney back she's controlling most of
the medes in the city so mr. Freeze's
back I love what the show did with that
character I thought the actor actually
did a really good job with it Firefly
and then you see Catwoman with the width
in a very Catwoman looking suit in fact
a couple of episodes the thomas wayne
character sort of like the Bruce clone
pushes her out a window in a bunch of
cats start climbing over her Michelle
Pfeiffer style it's a very Michelle
Pfeiffer origin story she kind of looks
like Michelle Pfeiffer so it was a very
appropriate way to give her a version of
her origin story so that's all
going on with the Bruce character they
call this the heroes rise trailer so
Gotham has already been renewed for
another season and I think that it's
totally possible if they can climb to
like six or seven seasons that we would
see him in a Batman suit
Smallville style like he watched the
Smallville show in season after season
they just refused to let him fly he's
not going to be wearing any costumes or
capes but then slowly as they get to the
later seasons he gets a little bit
closer he becomes the red blur then
finally in the big finale boom you get
to see him in this suit so when they
first started this TV show that was the
big question
you know like season 1 episode 1 is he
ever going to wear this suit and it's
like well yeah if they can go long
enough based on his age right now I say
he still has a couple years to go but
the shaman in the comics is an actual
character they've changed them a bit for
this court of owls storyline in the
comics all he was was just the last
person to give Bruce official training
before he returned to Gotham and put the
cowl on so they'd like them saying that
this is the last step in his training
before becoming Batman on the TV show so
I don't really know how they're going to
accelerate their plans because the way
the ratings are going they might get a
season five I don't know network
television is weird when it comes to
renewing shows but the finales next week
I'll be doing a bunch of DC TV stuff
throughout the summer including all the
CW stuff of course so if there any
Gotham bonus videos that you guys want
me to do or Batman related stuff just
let me know in the comments but I almost
forgot if you guys didn't hear Gotham is
actually moving to a separate night this
fall when season four comes back later
this year probably sometime late
September it's going to be on Thursday
nights so all of superhero TV is
shuffling nights just a little bit when
we get to Comic Con we start getting all
the trailers I'll do a video that will
explain when everything is happening
it's actually going to be a little bit
better everything isn't going to be on
the same two or three nights which is
kind of what's happening right now which
is a bit of a nightmare trying to keep
up with everything so next week we can
talk all about Batman racial Google on
Gotham versus arrow it'll be fun to
compare the two versions of the
character I'm a huge fan of Alexander
siddig I'm more of a fan of his Star
Trek stuff than I am of him from Game of
Thrones because they really raked him
over the coals on Game of Thrones well
later today
I'm gonna do is a DC TV video just
comparing all the finales because I feel
like you know like flash is way more
popular than the other DC TV shows but
arrow probably had the best finale in
Supergirl did a bunch of crazy stuff but
I feel like the show kind of gets
ignored so I'll do a video addressing
all those TV shows in what's going on
because most of them are hitting Netflix
this week so congratulations to the
latest giveaway winner Miguel Orozco
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details you can click here for
my non-spoiler rewinder woman review and
you can click here for a brand new flash
season 4th thank you so much for
watching let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight